qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise ce smartphone là ça ça
c'est extrêmement surprenant c'est le
nouveau au pot find x3 procès le
smartphone le plus haut de gamme de
l'opo pour 2021 l'année dernière déjà
avec le aux profanes x2 propres avait
frappé très fort à vous montrer les
muscles et là avec le finepix trois pros
il continue c'est assez démentiel et
c'est vachement intéressant donc
aujourd'hui on va se donner les
résultats complets je vais vous dire ce
que je pense de ses opposants x3 pro je
vais tout vous dire de tous les côtés et
je dois reconnaître que franchement au
pot vous m'avez vraiment bluffé avec ce
smartphone là parce que au-delà de la
fiche technique qui est juste énorme
derrière les promesses sont tenues et
c'est surtout ça qui vient m'intéresse
c'est ici
[Musique]
et ceci aussi est regardée lancera un
tout nouveau set up on essaye des choses
on a une nouvelle caméra on a de
nouveaux éclairages on essaye des choses
c'est sympathique on s'amuse donc
aujourd'hui on va se parler de ce
smartphone là et ce smartphone à saillat
lula plus de batterie ça commence bien
des gens voyez comment c'est quand on
commence à avoir un éclairage qui me
lachance et ce smartphone l'aï les
supras intéressant mois déjà le premier
truc qui m'a interpellé c'est quand aux
poètes arrive on les obtient regarder on
a un téléphone qui fait microscope j'ai
dit qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire
qu'est ce que je vais me refaire d'un
microscope sur un téléphone à l'effet
waouh c'est assez impressionnant tous
deux premiers qu'ils le fêtent puis je
me dis bon ok c'est un truc marketing
l'histoire d' appâter le consommateur
d'avoir une nouvelle techno convient
intégrés y aller pas forcément
extrêmement intéressante qu'est-ce que
je m'en fiche
et bien en fait c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal pourquoi donc ça permet de
redécouvrir le monde autour de nous
alors vous n'avez pas forcément tous les
jours à venir faire des photos au niveau
du microscope ça c'est une évidence mais
vous savez quand vous avez des enfants
vous voulez leur montrer un petit peu
des choses du vivant et bien tout ça
vraiment intéressant et même pour moi en
tant qu'adulte m'a vraiment fait marrer
de venir essayer de nouvelles choses
avec ce côté microscope donc ça je
trouve ça super intéressante
j'ai la lumière qui me lâche on va
continuer sans elle j'ai vraiment trouvé
ça extrêmement intéressant de
redécouvrir le monde d'une autre manière
ne serait ce que pour l'innovation pour
le fait de vous montrer ça comme ça ça
super intéressant après à côté de ça au
fond nous fait une très très belles
promesses au niveau de l'appareil photo
jusqu'à la restitution sur l'écran ils
vous disent on vous garantit un milliard
de couleurs c'est là que vous avez votre
smartphone vous le prenez vous allez
faire des photos et vous allez prendre
avec un milliard de couleurs et vous
allez avoir un milliard de couleurs qui
vont être restitués au niveau de votre
écran alors je n'ai pas mesuré les unes
après les autres et donc le milliard de
couleurs je pourrais pas vous le dire
mais ce que je peux vous dire dès
maintenant c'est que les photos elles
sont assez dingo ça marche super bien la
qualité de la dalle est vraiment là vous
avez une superbe dalle amoled qui dit
amoled samsung vous avez un écran avec
un taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
et de l'adaptative donc lorsque vous
n'avez pas besoin de son aide bien vous
n'êtes pas sur 200 m
mais lorsque vous venez jouer à des jeux
et bien vous avez du sang vert dès lors
qu'ils essaient citron du 120 hertz pour
tenir ce rôle est allé sur les
différents réseaux sociaux que vont être
installés compagnie je sais et que
sais-je encore eh bien ça va être
extrêmement cool et lorsque vous n'avez
pas besoin de ça que vous êtes sûre du
all ways and display et n'avait pas
besoin de ça y est vous n'êtes pas en
120 hertz
il vous est sûr jusqu'à dire
visionnage le fait d'avoir un écran de 6
70 pouces du quad hd plus c'est super
bien il marche vraiment bien vous avez
un très très bon rendu pour regarder des
films des séries du netflix que vous
voulez ce qui vous fera plaisir
eh bien vous l'avez vous avez un superbe
smartphone pour venir jouer à des jeux
vous avez de la performance le plus gros
sorte de qualcomm le plus gros
processeur celui qui marche le mieux
actuellement c'est le syndrome 888
couplé à pas moins de 12 giga de ram
avec la techno qui fonctionne le mieux
actuellement ces deux là est pas d hier
5 avec pas moins de 256 giga de stockage
c'est de lui fs 3.1
c'est ce qu'ils ratent plus vite aussi
actuellement en termes de lecture et
d'écriture alors ici le bémol c'est que
c'est pas extensibles mhz et 256 go de
stockage
franchement vous avez de quoi faire un
smartphone 5g double sim c'est juste une
une vraie bête de compet et rien que
pour ça je suis vraiment bluffé donc
fait tourner tout ce que vous voulez
dessus j'ai pu faire des jeux et
regarder des films des séries du
visionnage ouvert plein de trucs j'ai
pas réussi à le mettre à genoux donc ça
j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup en rien notre point qui
est assez intéressant sur ce smartphone
et qui est une des grosses forces de
repos c'est la charge
ici vous avez de la recharge c'est la
superbe look 2.0 et qu'est-ce que vous
permet de faire cette superbe look 2.0
vient déjà de recharger rapidement c'est
la moindre des choses c'est de la charge
65 watts ce qui fait que si vous tombez
un rade de batterie vous êtes à 0% et
bien en 30 minutes enfin moins de 30
minutes vous leur changer de 0 à 100%
c'est énorme ça veut dire que on va plus
posé la question du lammens combien de
temps il faut pour le recharger j'ai pu
le temps à genève a chargé hier soir je
suis embêté ce matin non ça c'est
terminé
vous le prenez vous le branchez vous
allez vous brosser les dents si vous
avez envie de brosser les dents
sinon faites ce que vous voulez et bien
en moins d'une demi-heure il est chargé
alors déjà ce que je vous conseillerais
vraiment c'est ne pas laisser se
décharger en dessous des 20% vous
recherchez jusqu'à 80% et vous êtes
tranquille donc ce qui fait que en un
quart d'heure à quelque chose près votre
smartphone il est chargé pour une
journée une journée et demie l'autonomie
derrière est pas mauvaise c'est pas ici
qu'on aura la meilleure autonomie mais
pour le garder une bonne journée sans
aucun problème vous êtes vraiment
tranquille donc ici vous avez vraiment
de quoi faire vous êtes tranquille ça
extrêmement rassurant et surtout et
technologique est vachement intéressante
derrière c'est que c'est une batterie
bis et l'ue et vous avez deux batteries
de 2250 milliampères heures pour un
total de 4500 millions perrin ce que va
venir faire et 6,7 cette charge en fait
c'est de la charge basse tension elle va
venir recharger chaque batterie
indépendamment celle panière stresser
les batteries de votre smartphone non
pas le stress je suis un peu stressée
endommagé en tout cas c'est ce que ça
veut dire
donc vous allez avoir une batterie qui
va durer beaucoup plus longtemps et
c'est techno elles sont propriétaires de
au pot et elles sont toujours bluffante
elle mange bien alors même si on n'a pas
la meilleure autonomie sur le marché on
peut recharger tellement rapidement
qu'on se pose plus de questions et en
plus si vous souhaitez vous à même de la
recharge sans fil 30 watts le fait
d'avoir un bon smartphone qui va vite
qui répond bien c'est une bonne chose
mais un autre pote est extrêmement
intéressant aussi sur l'expérience au
niveau sur smartphone c'est toute la
partie logicielle on veut qu'on
comprenne très facilement ces différents
paramètres on veut pas se prendre la
tête
et ici je peux vous assurer qu'avec
color os coloro s11 ils ont super bien
bossé d'ailleurs je vous ai fait une
vidéo pour vous parler de colo réponse
nous invite à venir la visionner journée
un lien quelque part par an ici ou en
bas allez jeter un oeil c'est plein
d'astuces pour bien utiliser que leurs
os 11 et si vous n'êtes pas coutumier de
l'euro elles sont si vous connaissez pas
toute cette expérience là bas vous allez
voir qu'il ya plein de super est sont
pas allés très loin on peut vraiment
devenir personnalisé customiser très
facilement tous à base et bien
évidemment sur un android 11 ça marche
super bien gardé ce design est vraiment
atypique à moi j'adore on est vraiment
quelque chose de très compact très léger
qui s'appelle 193 g
est ce que j'aime surtout c'est ça la
regarde et ça c'est tout nouveau c'est
vraiment différent différencions au
niveau du module photo là quelque chose
qui est pour le coup extrêmement
particulier c'est super agréable un
touché sous le doigt comme ça et sur un
marché où beaucoup de smartphones se
ressemble à beaucoup ça apporte une
vraie valeur et ça s'est super bien
s'il ya un point de se trouver un peu en
dessous pour voir que ce smartphone
scooter une plus de 1000 euros je vous
détailler le pays dans quelques instants
eh bien c'est la partie
des haut-parleurs stéréo lorsque vous le
tenez comme ça dans votre main qu'est ce
qui va se passer au niveau des hauts
parleurs c'est que vous avez votre
premier haut parleurs qui est situé
juste en dessous là c'est votre
haut-parleurs principal est le deuxième
il va se situer juste là ce qui fait que
vous avez une asymétrie parce que vous
écoutez de la musique avec le son qui va
partir de ce côté là et qui va partir
comme ça donc c'est pas complètement
idéal vous allez avoir une bien
meilleure expérience avec le rock phone
5 d'asus clairement ici c'est un peu en
dessous par rapport au reste
quand je dis pas que c'est mauvais c'est
pas mauvais mais c'est vrai que vu la
qualité de la dalle vu la qualité du
processeur vu toutes les qualités de ce
smartphone
cette partie là mériteraient d'être
retravaillées pour avoir une vraie
expérience de stéréoscopie parce qu'on
va prendre son smartphone à la main pour
venir écouter de la musique pour venir
regarder un film pour regarder une série
où quand on vient jouer à des jeux
c'est un peu le truc qui est un peu un
peu en tous un peu dommage alors bien
évidemment comme on est sur un
smartphone trendy sommes ici aujourd'hui
bien vous n'allez pas avoir de prise
jack
on trouve plus aujourd'hui par contre
vous avez du bluetooth 5.2 avec plein de
codecs à ptx à ptx tws plus elle hdc
el'dak sbc est assez autant dire que là
l'offre est complète et vous avez de
quoi faire pour le gaming c'est un
produit qui est vraiment fabuleux taux
d'échantillonnage tactile qui va jusqu'à
241 films séries ça roule gaming ça
roule
photo ap photo c'est pas mal photo et un
taux qui m'a vachement intéressés si
vous voulez lorsque vous avez
usuellement sur des smartphones un
capteur grand-angle et un ultra grand
angle a toujours une différence de
colorimétrie parce qu'on n'a pas les
mêmes capteurs ici avoir trouvé un
capteur qui est développée spécialement
pour ce smartphone qui est fait par sony
s'est uni mx 766 qu'on va retrouver
aussi bien sur votre grand-angle que sur
votre ultra grand angle au niveau de la
photo à voir 3 capteur à l'arrière un
premier capteur 50 méga pixels c'est un
grand-angle f 1.8 stabilisation optique
et électronique et surtout vu un
autofocus omnidirectionnelle vous a
également dû très grand-angle 50 méga
pixels tout rêve 2.2 avec un champ de
vision de 110 du 3° avec également
l'autofocus omnidirectionnelle qui vous
permettra de faire de la macro ya quatre
centimètres le téléobjectif est aussi
intéressant c'est pas le même capteur
vous avez un zoom optique x 2,1 me bride
x 5 et un zoom numérique jusqu'à x 20 on
n'a pas de x 30 x 50 x 100 aurait pu
s'attendre à ce qu'ils aillent plus loin
avec au moins un zoom optique x 5 voire
fois disent pourquoi pas pourquoi pas un
double t l'objectif ici c'est pas le cas
mais par contre moi ce que je souligne
une fois de plus c'est vraiment ce côté
très audacieux d'avoir mis une caméra
micro scope
que je trouvais pas forcément
extrêmement dingo la première fois que
j'ai vu une pique au final j'ai fait de
bien parce qu'on découvre le monde d'une
autre façon et on se l'approprient
différemment j'ai quelques photos que je
suis venu vraiment faire avec la
fonction microscope
au début j'ai découvert c'est quand même
bluffant on est vraiment du tissu l'a
vraiment s'imaginer qu'on est en
profondeur dans le tissu regardez là ce
qu'on arrive à choper
c'est un insecte alors je m'appelle pas
exactement quels insectes c'était
j'étais très très près de l'insecte on
est vraiment dans toute intimité l'huile
allez on passe pareil là on était sûrs
quoi là je sais plus haut c'est un
espèce de v recrutement mort ça deviner
ce que c'est ça c'est très drôle ça à
votre avis qu'est ce que c'est ça dit
clément commentaire reste 30 secondes
en fait ça c'est une petite coccinelle
regardez là c'est drôle quand on y pense
ce qu'on arrive à choper à redécouvrir
le vivant c'est ça qui m'intéresse
alors là c'est pareil ça tout petit
insecte alors faut trouver la bonne
position c'est un peu le le gros enjeu
du truc là regardez là haut up pas mal
je suis vraiment très très proches sur
le sol up l'arrêt laisser ça là ce tout
petit insecte c'est extrêmement
extrêmement extrêmement bluffant le
regard est ce que c'est ça aussi c'est
cool c'est c'est ça en fait c'est cette
espèce de pissenlit
alors ça c'est un peu plus dur aussi
avoir c'était lui alors là on s'attendre
là dans la campagne en dreyer parce que
j'aime beaucoup et se sont super
intéressant ici c'est que si vous
regardez par exemple dans votre capteur
principal et que vous souhaitez sur
l'ultra grand-angle et bien comme vous
êtes sur le même capteur exactement le
sonic et 1766 eh bien vous avez
exactement mais exactement les mêmes
couleurs c'est préserver et ça c'est
vraiment mais vraiment super bien on va
changer de couleur lorsqu'on va se
pencher ensuite sur votre télé objectif
là on voit on n'est plus sûr du jaune
marronner on perd un peu ce côté ce côté
bleu on peut se rapprocher un petit peu
je dirais que x 2 x 5 ça fonctionne
partir du foie dit ça commence vraiment
à piquer les yeux
il faut à 20 on oubliait caméra
principale l'ultra grand angle on se
rapproche on se rapproche on se
rapproche encore et paf on arrive dans
l'arbre et ça c'est très drôle real et
on est vraiment dans la grâce au
microscope
si vous voulez aller visiter un petit
peu de bois de prêt à regarder hop là
paf dans le bois bon pas toujours simple
à trouver sa bonne position ça qu'est ce
que c'est de la même manière attendez je
vous ramène ça c'était exactement
c'était ça en fait ça je sais pas si
vous avez deviné c'est assez rigolo
betemit une petite pause j'ai dit moi en
commentaire ce que c'est ça à votre avis
qu'est ce que c'est vous êtes prêts stop
c'est un panneau stop vue très très près
au microscope
ça que j'aime bien vraiment bien re
découvrir complètement son son
environnement saas et de la glace ça ça
en fait c'est de la neige et de la glace
pris en photo de près c'est vraiment
très très bluffant beau même sur le côté
ici là les des petites gouttes c'est
très très très très très drôle
bon ça c'est la caméra de sel fille elle
fonctionne pas mal c'est pas la plus
dingue ou de tous mais elle fera le taf
le mode portrait fonctionne bien il a eu
un petit peu de mal si on les hautes
lumières au niveau du nez ça me va bien
cramé mais ça ça dépend des photos il ya
des fois où même le feu des fois où il
ne le fait pas alors sans discontinuer a
qu'un petit golf ça on s'en fiche
les photos de nature dans l'ensemble
j'aime bien ça fonctionne vraiment bien
c'est une gestion de la plage dynamique
qui vraiment pas mal du tout ils ont
fait un travail mené un travail au pot
au niveau de la photo là dessus alors
ils vont pas aussi loin que certains
comme je vous le disais avec un zoom x
50 x 100 et là la regarder ça essayez de
deviner ce que c'est ça c'est très très
très très bluffant
à votre avis qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc non je vous laisse deviner c'est c
à c ur en fait c'est assez ouf sais pas
si vous ignorez en fait ça c'est une
abeille vous êtes sur le dos d'une
abeille
alors j'ai tué aucune abeille et pour
faire ces photos je vous rassure une
béquille était déjà morte s'est trouvée
morte mais super bien conservé donc vous
pouvez vraiment redécouvrir le vivant
redécouvrir le monde sac et qui vraiment
impatient ça en fait c'est l'oeil de
l'abeille que vous avez ici là oui et ça
c'est quand même le fond et on vendange
précisé du pollen qu'elle a sur elle
soudainement les abeilles elle récupère
le pollen oms en mettant sur elle et
elle le ramène elle le mène dans la
ruche comme ça comme ça on fait un peu
de nature en même temps eh bien je pense
être un poil de pollen qui est qui
restent et ouais c'est super super super
bluffant donc je vais même faire de la
vidéo microscope de ce trailer de venir
me balader partout alors il yad'autres
tout cas ça l'intégration pour venir
filmer bien évidemment sur quatre cas 60
images par secondes et vous avez un mode
qui est super cool pour tous les
vidéastes amateurs
eh bien vous avez un mode film à voir ce
mode film il vous permet quoi et vous
permet de venir aller dans les
paramètres plus en profondeur pour
l'utiliser comme si vous utilisiez un
petit boîtier numérique et vous avez
même une option log pour venir mettre
des locks au film et flatte comme on le
ferait avec une caméra ou comme je le
fais tout de suite avec les aimons
moitié de sony et vous venez appliquer
une colorimétrie sur le dessus je vous
montre ça c'est vraiment bluffant
vous avez un truc qui est hyper fatah
regarder la sas et flatte de chez flat
là je suis en 4k 60 images par seconde
seulement ça va venir bouger ou pourra
réussir à le stabiliser si on le
souhaite un mais bon là pour coup
c'était pas du tout stabiliser mais on
est vraiment sûr du flat alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que si vous le
souhaitez et bien au pot vous a mis à
dispo sur leur site un petit lot 1
mettra de le convertir en règle 709 donc
la regarde et hop là je voulais
appliquer ici je le mets déjà ça vous
l'a convertie donc ça déjà c'est assez
rigolo et après si vous souhaitez pas
vous pouvez venir appliquer des lettres
je vous en ai mis un par dessus ça va
venir type et l'image
si vous voulez avoir un effet
cinématiques regardez là je l'enlève je
le remets frais dans un blockbuster avec
avec les playmobil scooby doo
regardez là hop je l'enlève c'est plus
flat je leur mets et vins et tout de
suite ça va venir type et votre image
donc si vous voulez venir faire de la
réalisation pourquoi pas pour avoir un
smartphone en plus et bien pouvait faire
des choses c'est assez rigolo
donc c'est en ça que j'aime bien ça
cette partie photo parce que je la
trouve extrêmement polyvalente avec d'un
côté tout ce module photo qui est
polyvalent alors qu'il n'a pas aussi
loin que certains keira pas aussi loin
le samsung galaxy s 21 ultra mais qui
par contre ce qui fait il le fait
merveilleusement bien il le fait très
bien
on va pas venir ou métro ou bien jusqu'à
du x 5 au delà c'est pas officines mais
fait d'avoir le même capteur sur le
grand temps ultra grand-angle c'est
super bien
le fait d'avoir cette vidéo la
possibilité de filmer en flat ça c'est
aussi super bien il ya plein de petits
mode différent avec de l'expérience
qu'ils sont super intéressante au pot a
bien réfléchi a bien bossé je pense
qu'il pourrait encore aller plus loin
notamment avec un zoom périscopique
pourquoi pas un double tels objectifs
qu'ils viendraient vraiment rapporter
encore plus à l'expérience et le mettre
au niveau notamment d'un samsung galaxy
s 21 ultra sur cette partie là avec un
zoom périscopique centre on va y revenir
dans peut-être l'année prochaine mais en
tout cas ce qui est là comme ces faits
là c'est très bien maîtrisée et c'est
vraiment super bon on a bien évidemment
une double simon n'a du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé et notamment
google paye on a un smartphone qui est
certifié ip 68 qu'un écran qui luttent
contre la lumière bleue on a du wifi 6
août bref on à la complète et tout ça
pour 1149 euros alors c'est quand même
un certain prix une certaine somme 1149
euros c'est énorme et 149 euros mais
pour 1149 euros
vous avez un milliard de couleurs de
côté et l'autre et surtout un ensemble
caméra qui marche super bien sûr on
pourrait regretter là dessus c'est se
dire que et bien on a pas de lasers pour
avoir un focus beaucoup plus rapide n'a
pas de caméra tu offres saas aurait pu
être intéressant à presque 1200 euros
d'avoir ça aujourd'hui on ne l'a pas
malgré tout les techno
j sont là les innovations sont la lada
est vraiment bien terme de photos vous
avez ce qu'il faut en terme de vidéo et
bien vous avez aussi ce qu'il faut on a
de la performance la province un
smartphone qui est extrêmement complet
qui va être très polyvalent qui va péter
niché dans un domaine en particulier
mais si vous voulez un super beau
smartphone une expérience android qui
marche vachement bien avec color os 11
et bien vous avez vraiment de quoi faire
avec sopo find x3 pro personnellement je
suis vraiment très très fan et je trouve
super intéressant il est un peu en
dessous au niveau des hauts parleurs
tels qu'ils sont positionnés comme ça il
est un peu en dessous au niveau de
l'autonomie
il ya quelques petits trucs qui aurait
pu être ajoutée au niveau de la photo on
verra sur un repos find x4 pro l'année
prochaine en tout cas ce qui est là et
comme il est fabriqué tout de suite ce
que vous assurer que vous avez pour
votre argent
ça reste beaucoup d'argent mais 149
euros mais le smartphone est tellement
beau tellement bien réussi j'adore ce
côté très chanceux tient tellement mal
en main il est léger il a nécessité un
peu particulière et la recharge
tellement rapide de la performance vous
avez compris en tout cas j'aime beaucoup
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous de
ceux au phoenix 3 pro en bas en
commentaire vous très intéressant il
pourrait vous tentez est-ce que vous
avez déjà acheté un smartphone de repos
le pauvre mx2 pro l'année dernière
d'ailleurs si vous avez aimé au phénix
de pros ne changeait pas c'est un très
beau smartphone nouveau finepix de pro +
3 pro et très très cool donc si vous
êtes dans l'idée ou dans l'optique de
changer de smartphone why not ça peut le
faire alors on se teste très bientôt le
openx trois néo et son petit frère
le light aussi il a light que le nom
parce qu'on est vraiment dans le milieu
de gamme avec un smartphone qui est très
intéressant qu'il faut aussi de très
jolies promesses donc ces deux là ont
ces tests très prochainement j'invite
donc à vous abonner à rester connectés
pour qu'on regarde ça ensemble voilà un
jeu vous n envoyez vos bijoux de l'amour
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao